l'automne dernier un organisme de
défense des droits des minorités
sexuelles a lancé une campagne de
sensibilisation pour lutter contre les
stéréotypes en milieu rural des
agriculteurs nous explique pourquoi on a
encore besoin de faire campagne en ce
sens
en ville il ya un peu plus de gènes hla
iront pas de crier à ce titre en plein
milieu de la rue ici ça va pouvoir dès
fois arrivé
là on arrive ici on est un couple
binational on est un couple homo
parentales
on est agricultrice on a deux filles
sont pas de la même couleur ça faisait
beaucoup
quand je les dis que je t'ai dit il a
raison dans une taille il peut pas de
producteur s'il veut vivre sa vie des
lignes fixes en laye à montréal plus de
20 de quoi faire au style et son prix
importent ses sauts
si françois van issue à la direction
générale du groupe régional
d'intervention sociale le gris en
mauricie centre du québec
[Applaudissements]
le domaine agricole et 1,2 un milieu qui
est encore très hétéronormatif des
hommes musclés donc son qui reprennent
l'entreprise familiale par exemple
pourront fonder leur famille on leur
ferme on les enfants le but de la
campagne c'était de faire tomber les
préjugés
[Musique]
ak
qu'ils veuillent saison
[Musique]
maintenant je suis copropriétaire de
l'asinerie des enfants qui lot avec ma
conjointe on est situé à cette anarchie
ce qui va déranger ce qu'on soit 2
femmes sur une ferme les monsieur y
arrivent ici ils se demandent bien où
l'homme
on a des ânesses le tiers
donc nos ânesse et produisent du lait
avec lequel on fait des cosmétiques
on accueille des gens sur la ferme l'été
en tourisme
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois où la dame
du congo dit oui mais le traiteur pièces
qui conduit tu rates of oz un pam mais
c'est ma blonde qui consultent pas
[Musique]
mon nom est des voeux laverie j'habite à
saint cyprien dans la région couleurs du
loup j'ai 43 ans et je suis trop star de
l'est
c'est
et
ben moi des fois je me dis les temps les
producteurs délégués
tu seras mon fils ben oui c'est vrai
c'est tellement ancré dans les gens dans
la société que sauvage et ses destinées
[Musique]
c'est alain charles court sic j'ai laisé
présentement saint charles de
bellechasse
j'ai aussi un autre vent qui aimons sur
donc tout le monde m'appelle c'est alix
de courcy qui est mon médecin en tant qu
drag queen
[Musique]
je suis ferme y est maintenant faite
agriculteurs la vie avec les animaux
salle à un rythme qui est complètement
différent de celui du moins c'est ce
qu'ils font non le tout en partant c'est
on est en cours
on est là vous nous prenez commune et on
avait tous les deux le même rail
j'aurais jamais fait tout seul je suis
certaine qu'en 50 senti des préjugés
envers vous oui
soit c'était les propriétaires de
magasins qu'on rentrait locke le regard
c'était je pense que j'avais été chez
pas moins de marie losique qui a fait
rentrer ça reste le même effet l'eau et
je me suis même déjà fait refuser
l'entrée en faisant dire des personnes
comme toi on propre site
[Musique]
manal et tahiti ok donc détail il sa vie
et de mort
le problème est arrivé pour ça il était
il est à beaufort
ça arrive est ce que vient il y en a
encore qui sait deux monts phobie dans
le milieu agricole et rural oui oui un
jeu tant qu'hôte d'homophobie mid de ses
parents le jeune garçon s'était dans les
plans qui agitent la ferme familiale
finalement legault rencontre un autre
garçon tant d'amour le dit à sa famille
de ses parents ses parents le prenne
mais pour mais vraiment pour y ont
profité de ce truc qui est absent ils
ont tous produit n'ont pu discuter
l'entreprise puis sont pas de lutter
c'est pas vrai qu'une tape est vraiment
ce que ma famille ait construit c'est
pas si loin
ces points 4 ans peut-être
ah ouais
j'ai vécu toute ma jeunesse en campagne
j'ai travaillé dans les fermes j'ai
travaillé aussi dans les écuries
en réalité ce succès en ville
probablement qui en avait vu d'autres
comme moi l'oeil avait une séance
lochte est vraiment unique j'étais
vraiment
j'étais là ta tête du coin sauva le
lendemain je vivais des problèmes est
énorme
2 2 d'un jeu de l'injustice autres bref
j'y vais le préjugé leopard est ce que
les enfants connaissent pas ce qui se
passe mais c'est eux qui le font jeu d
enfant
c'est mes chefs
à l'époque on avait une blonde d'autres
cachés les attentes
un moment donné je me suis dit si ça
marche plus le cemoc si vraiment
question j'ai souhaité que j'arrête seul
homme je m'amuse et des idées noires on
se le cachera pas ou ce que je finis
cela la relation ou que je finis mes
villes aussi un rouleau je m'en tiens
quand même bon choix de vie le taux de
suicide chez les agriculteurs quand est
encore très élevé ce sont des personnes
qui sont grandement isolé aussi dans
leur quotidien on se lève tôt on se
couche tard donc on est constamment 24
heures sur 24 sur la ferme mais qu'en
plus on agriculteurs se questionne sur
son orientation sexuelle ou même son
identité de genre
ça doit être problématique en bout de
ligne nous pour la santé montante de la
personne combien les mym objets qui sont
partis de la campagne de montmagny qui
sont partis de saint damien
parce qu'il pouvait plus rester y leurs
familles mais pour ça qu'ils sont
homosexuels comme un citron pas de
support de tours de ta propre famille
komatsu veut sortir de tout ça c'est
vraiment la solitude qui devient le plus
grand problème en région pour les gens
mot sexuelle ou est-ce qu'on va se
retrouver c'est qui qui peut parler avec
tous pourrait parler de ma réalité mon
dieu j'ai dur de faire deux maisons
enclos je suis obligé de penser mais mes
brebis puis demain soir jean-claude drag
queen à qui je pourrai parler de ce
même mes parents quand ça s'est su les
autres aussi maman la première affaire
montre encore plus de relief
c'est fini elle faisait des deuils moins
de gants beaucoup de deuil est le joyau
mon avenir qui s'écroulait
même mon père t il n'a jamais côtoyé il
finança temps et puis je mens la mort
est un plus
tu as bien braconniers que ce à quoi je
serais pas où là moi le premier
l'apparenté sédégo qui promène en string
sponsors c'est tellement une minorité
mais ne sont en région tous convoitent
et les six ans
on va voir un couple d'hommes ce qu'on
va s'imaginer ben c'est eux
dgo sur un char allégorique avec des
plumes donc je pense que les gens la
population en général voient ne vois que
ça puis ça dérange un peu plus
nous on vit beaucoup en famille donc ce
qui est accepté c'est la famille
peut-être que la population en général
pouvoir soit plus naturel soit l'école
florent se faisait dire à et florent est
chanceuse elle a le 12 mai à se faisait
pas dire florennes à la porte par les
gens posent des questions on leur répond
puis on ne choisit d'être complètement
transparent je rencontre une madame
alice free
elle nous demande aux le père il doit
dont il doit avoir une belle couleur de
peau le juge dit ben nous on ne choisit
un donneur qui était haïtien puis là je
vois le vide dans ses yeux le promoteur
clash est obligé d'aller d'aller plus
loin et puis lui dire ben oui c'est ma
conjointe qui le porte et puis on a eu
besoin de donneurs de sperme
donc on est allé vers 20 randonneurs qui
étaient mulâtre mais pourquoi accepter
de répondre à des questions comme ça
aussi intime parce que ça mais c'est
juste notre façon faire avancer les
choses c'est moi je bloque à raconter
l'histoire de la base de notre famille
quel message envoie aussi à mes enfants
à mes enfants
alors amis à l'école ou ou à lahmada mon
village
dans le fond tout samedi que ton
personnage de jack en campagne milieu
agricole sa pose pas problème non sa
pose pas de problème de ce côté-là
[Musique]
ça
c'est un show les gens le sentent ça
s'est bien passé parce qu'on avait de
l'ouverture d'esprit et parce qu'on est
allé chercher les gens ont séparé tous
notre homosexuels t on a voulu aller
plus loin on est des êtres humains et
l'autre se sait ce qu'on a vu d'abord le
puits les gens l'ont pris comme ceux
êtes aussi ce que tu m'expliques sais
que ton père était homophobe
oui qu'est ce qui s'est produit quand tu
as annoncé autant il était de ce côté là
le autant ça a viré complètement aux
côtés de prendre l'argent pour leur foi
en plus d'y jeter comme baky koné c'est
pour ça et on n'a toujours pas de ce
qu'on connaît peu importe c'est quoi
mais lui c'était ça qui justement qu'on
veut me met pas souvent dans le village
aussi je me pose beaucoup de questions
je vais pas leur manquer pied à
l'épicerie à quincaillerie peu importe
si j'ai jamais vu de hockey
pourquoi toi tu as accepté de nous
accorder une entrevue dans le cadre de
ce reportage là pour donner de l'espoir
on donnait de l'espoir dire aussi que la
différence se vit aujourd'hui que vous
soyez en ville où que vous soyez en
contact il y aura toujours toujours
toujours dit que je fais juste aller au
bout de soi thorez à l'isie votre avance
pour tous
[Musique]
jeudi
je trouve qu'on connait un modèle
équilibré concept est gris dans la dans
l'eau dans la vie rurale s'adonne que
c'est ici
sens caché sans faire trop nous filles
sont comme les autres c'est juste de
montrer qu'on est comme tout le monde je
comprends qu'un hack qui veulent pas en
parler publiquement
moi ça me dérange pour parce que je vis
bien avec ce que je suis je vis bien
avec mon conjoint qui sont tous montre
aux gens qu'on parle ans fermes
laitières et des encours heureux merci
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]